so first of all i want to talk about of
course the beast must die
yeah how intense was this experience for
you because this is a very intense show
it is a very intense show um i'm not
going to lie
it it stayed with me francis the
character has stayed with me
for quite a while afterwards um
it was quite an emotional challenge to
do it
i'm not a method actor i kind of like
use a lot of substitution but i think
the thing with acting and the body and
the brain is like your brain knows that
you're just going to work for 12 hours a
day and that you're acting
but your body if you're crying for 10 of
the 12 hours
every day then your body like doesn't
know so you get the end of the week
you're like god i feel really depressed
i wonder why i feel depressed
because we've been crying all week
nobody died
um so yeah so it was it was a hard one
and but i really weirdly enjoyed it
because it was challenging and it
stretched me and yeah it was
very fulfilling you know um you know and
being a mom yourself does a role like
this hit a little differently
yeah i think i'm i mean i'm pretty sure
anybody could empathize with the idea of
losing a child that they know
not just losing them in a tragic way but
in such an
unjust way such an unfair way and then
dying
you know alone like that um but yeah i
have a three-year-old and he
moved with me to the isle of wight while
i was shooting and
oh my god it i think three years before
i would have found a way to empathize
but it does become a little bit
different
when you're realizing you know a child's
life gets stopped at that time and it
can't continue and you're going to
always be thinking about the things they
don't get to do
which kind of follows you around you
know
so yeah it was it does ring a little bit
different when you've got that but
i got to go home and play with him at
the end of the day which was always
always helpful
yes that's i would assume very
therapeutic at the end of the day
very therapeutic until he you know and
until he does a huge poop or something
and then you're like maybe i don't need
this therapy right now maybe
you know this is too hard this is uh i
love this
yeah you know when i think of jared
harris
to me he's always gonna be moriarty he
just plays such a good
villain obviously showing his villain
aside in this series what was it like
working with him
oh so fabulous he gets embarrassed when
i talk about him because he
was really so brilliant he is very
experienced
he has been doing this longer than me
i'm going to put it that way
days old because he hates that and you
don't always get the kind of
support that i received from him when
you are younger and
and to be honest a girl you know
oftentimes you're carrying a lot on your
shoulders but
you don't really get that support when
somebody's so experienced and it's done
so much and he was just the most
amazing scene partner he really really
understood how much of the show i was
carrying
and how emotional it was and he also
knew i think and nothing really comes
across as he knew the key to george was
really discovering that
charm and charisma and magnetism
because that's the kind of person that
ends up being able to manipulate other
people
um and he does that like you said so
well
um that we would be doing quite dark
scenes together
and then you know five minutes like i
would be rolling around laughing because
he's
just like he's just such a good time so
i felt so
blessed to be playing opposite him and
and um yeah he was it was great having
him there
yeah no you're right he has that charm
right it's so dangerous but it's
charming yes exactly i love that you
know
so many people found love with you on
the good wife and of course the good
fight um when you're playing a character
like luka quinn for a number of years
what would you say was your biggest
takeaway from playing that role what did
you learn the most from
oh well i learned a hell of a lot about
the law i tell you that much
i um i have when i get some time i keep
saying this but when i get some time i
would actually like to try to take the
bar exam
because i didn't just learn a lot about
the law i actually got super interested
in it
and the way that it works and um and was
like god i need to like study this
i found it a lot like um it was it was
the biggest
tv job that i've done that really
crossed over with
the theater that i've done in terms of
especially in terms of the way you work
in court
it's very wordy you have to know exactly
what you're saying you have to know the
melody of an argument
and um it became kind of something that
luca did
well um so i think i just learned a lot
about
technically learning pages and pages and
pages of pages of dialogue
and making sure that it didn't sound
boring um but also
i just got to work with the most
incredible people with
um christine and the whole crew and
the writing was amazing and i just
learned that um
a collaboration is is really the best
way to make a really great show
the writers listen to the actors the
actors listen to the writers
and the producers and that's how we kind
of
made it work and so now when i now when
i work on jobs where that's not
happening i'm
kind come on you guys do you not want
the best out of this like it's about the
collab
so um yeah i think that's the biggest
thing that i learned
oh i love that and i feel like too
there's confidence about this character
too that people could really connect
with
yeah she's way more ballsy than me i
mean luke luka says and does things that
i'd be like
[Applause]
never say that but that's kind of
cathartic
right because we all i think especially
as women we have lots of things that we
want to blur out at times or we just
want to be like i'm not doing that or
i'm not doing that that way
and um we just don't because we we know
we shouldn't
and we don't want to upset anybody or
offend anybody and we want people to
like us
so um but lukashi does not care for that
and i
used to find it quite cathartic to um
do that through luca also she has some
damn good clothes
i'm not gonna lie to you that was a huge
part of why i enjoyed her and every
season they got better and every season
we'd be like she'd never be able to
afford this skirt
don't care looks fabulous looks amazing
on her that's amazing
[Laughter]
you missed that wardrobe i see that now
um obviously fans were sad when you left
the good
fight but i was reading that you left to
go back to the uk and you spent time
with your family so how important was
that time for you
um yeah it's been it's been uh it's been
a real roller coaster because
really the only reason why i decided to
leave was that i felt like luca's story
had come to an
end and i've never been somebody that
um will stay doing something if i start
to feel like i'm getting a little itchy
like i need to challenge myself a bit
then i just move i move on because i
think in my job
um a lot of creative jobs probably but
in my job
you only get better by pushing yourself
a bit further and pushing yourself a bit
further and
and trying to see like will i fail at
this or i'll try this
you don't get better by just stagnating
in one place and so
it felt comfortable to be luca but
should i be comfortable or should i try
to be a bit uncomfortable
and then the other side of it was i have
a three-year-old he was born in new york
and new york's been amazing but my whole
family and friends are here
sure my husband's family and friends are
here and i have loads of siblings and
they all have kids my son's age
so basically what i wanted was free
babysitting
and also um i wanted my son
to have cousins that are like siblings
and it's difficult to do that when you
live
transatlantically and i know that sounds
crazy because i'm an actor
um and i should you know should i don't
know be in hollywood or something but
i don't know my my baseline has always
been like if i'm not happy in my life
then i'm not gonna make good work
so i try to be driven by that and then
hope that the work
will will come wherever i go you know
well then obviously the work is coming
with a series like this i mean this just
really puts you at the forefront and it
really shows off at a good afternoon
like honestly yeah i mean honestly it's
just such a
you know rules like this you don't
always see roles like this so it's
uh yeah so no it's a really special
series if your son
ever was interested in working as an
actor would you encourage them
god i know when people ask me this okay
here's what i think
yeah if if he showed attitude
beyond the school play i don't mean like
oh isn't he a great
angel gabriel or shepherd or something
but like
if like me and i've never wanted to be
anything else it was all i was driven by
from three or four years old
my parents were nurses they had no idea
why i wanted to do it but they supported
me
because it's what i kept saying i wanted
to do and i happen to be maybe like okay
at it
right um if he was like that and he had
the bug
and he really was going to work hard i
would absolutely support him
but if he was not very good
you'd be honest or you know i would
encourage him
to keep his options open um because
uh i think if i had been um
you know if i had the opportunity to
learn more in other areas or maybe go to
better schools
or um anything like that which i
couldn't really afford to do
um i might have ended up in a different
area and i just think with kids it's
like you what all you want is for your
kids to be happy and enjoy the work
they do i do think it's really tough to
be the kid of an actor
um because you're always going to you
know compare yourself and
do i wanted to be no i want him to do
another job
that makes loads of money and then look
after me when i'm old that's what
if it's acting fine just be a good one
yeah
and make lots of money